hey other gumballs
welcome to jim fails i did a video like
this before
and i didn't understand anything it was
so confusing to me
i had never heard about planet fitness
before
now i know okay i know i know
because it was so confusing to me here
i'll show an example
i watched his gym fail compilation video
and i didn't understand why it all was
from the same gym
why are people doing this
game god game god
oh that's he's activating his entire
core
do you understand how strong it will be
the thing is i don't how do you use
these machines isn't that for your back
no way it isn't i don't know i don't
know all i know is he's not doing it
right
god i think everyone's everyone that
goes to the
gym secret nightmare is that they're
going to be the ones
filmed you didn't have perfect form that
one push right
and they you're just going to be
ridiculing the internet what is that
that's not even a full movement you
[ __ ] beta but this is just on another
level
i mean it's all the same gym
planet fitness oh
why is it so funny we developed the
machines
but the humans couldn't decipher what
the ancient artifacts were meant to do
so yeah people basically explain that
planet fitness
is the walmart version of gym it's
absolutely beautiful
and the best part about it which makes
absolutely no [ __ ] sense
whatsoever is that planet fitness has a
no
shame uh some sort of no
shame attitude which makes sense right
let's see like you belong
it's it's the gym for people that don't
feel comfortable with the whole
jim bro culture every gym is different
to be fair some are more somewhere less
it depends what you enjoy uh but you
belong
you belong here yeah look how nice it's
so corporate
yeah look at that you belong everyone
can jim it's like
10 bucks to sign up which i assume is
very cheap
yes yeah yeah yeah
this is so good they have this thing
called a lunk alarm
which is an alarm i don't know what lunk
means
uh it's they decided that it was a good
idea uh
that if you make too much noise in the
gym
they'll sound the lunk alarm the holy
spirit
you guys start banging that barbell it's
really annoying
and i'm going to teach a yoga class very
shortly and when people
bang those barbells on the floor it gets
me really annoyed
okay sorry it's not good enough stop
banging it sorry it's not good enough
i get it in some in some sense i get it
it's annoying
uh if you're not putting down the lifts
properly
but the thing is some type of exercises
are just
very very difficult to not make any
noise
sorry it's not good enough dead lifting
being a good example
[Music]
you gotta stop lifting weights at the
gym stop it
[Laughter]
maybe they should have a different room
for dead lift i don't know uh i don't
know if i reacted to this but this
video is [ __ ] crazy
here comes the lunk alarm
[Music]
look at this [ __ ]
he [ __ ] kicks it out of him did he
kick him in his balls what happened
there
[ __ ] you're out
you're out he's not even he's not even a
manager
whoa
i'm waiting get out that's not
i think i'm more pissed this kid than to
knock his ass out this was in my city
the guy got banned for life and the kid
being pushed out was giving a lifetime
membership for him
and his family damn dude is right up and
can't control himself but thank
hey [ __ ] justin wang is in the
comments dan doesn't make my blood boil
he smells like he's holding back tears
but he goes you're ego lifting
so yeah i guess my point is yeah some
exercises uh
it's very difficult to do silent this is
how it's done
hey i'm the same ones for the wrist
[Laughter]
anyway so so back to planet fitness
right
they have this lunk alarm that is
uh lunk apparently it's a slang for
someone who grunts or drop weights or
or judges or judges
ricky's slamming his weights wearing a
bodybuilding tank top and drinking
out of a gallon water jug what a what a
luck
what the [ __ ] is hold up you're not
allowed to drink out of it
what am i some sort of lunk what is this
i need to be hydrated
what the [ __ ]
i had no idea you're not allowed to
drink out of big water bottles
how dare you not wanting to refill your
water bottle
but the irony is also like don't judge
but yeah if you make too much
noise we'll sound the alarm so you get
uh so you get judged the [ __ ] out of the
place
obviously people going in making
deliberate noises just [ __ ] cringe as
well
like some of these youtube videos i was
trying to find an example of the lunk
[Music]
alarm
dude i would feel more pumped i'm like
yeah [ __ ] yeah i'm doing it right
i could already imagine an old man
getting flashed by the animatronic yeah
what kind of
what kind of [ __ ] alarm is that that
that just sounds badass dude like
they're going to [ __ ] war there needs
to be some
it needs to be something uh embarrassing
like [ __ ] fart noises or some [ __ ]
the thing is i i can kind of see the
point it is annoying when people grunt
excessively it's like dude just [ __ ]
shut up
all right i get grunting but not that
much you're just sounding like a [ __ ]
ape all right
stop it you're annoying but um yeah
[ __ ] planet fitness it's so [ __ ]
funny
and it's just no judgement gets judged
online
oh gosh
okay hell yeah
i just don't understand the need to
invent
all these new moves must be january
again
[ __ ] january man it's so [ __ ]
annoying too because everyone will just
be gone
by the end of the month it's such a
weird thing oh yeah i reacted to this
this is like a professional wrestling
room so i guess some
it's legit i was wrong gamers
it does look very silly though i'm not
gonna lie is that
what isn't that just supporting its
weight
that's his health i am
so confused the thing is
that a lot of people comment pointed out
in the comments as well was that
there are instructions here look on the
left there are instructions
on each equipment saying how you should
use it there should be no confusion
this man exercised his mind and his
muscles at the same
time the true fit late oh
oh there's no judgment here no lunker
normal
alarm necessary between every rep
i i grow my mind i actually train at one
of these if you know what you're doing
you can get a get damn good workout in
uh most people have no idea what you're
doing and drawn to this place like flies
so you get a bunch of ego lifters and
just general idiots it's always funny to
watch
although i'd say 90 of people in there
are normal gym goers but there's always
that one idiot that shines out the rest
i mean yeah i'm pretty sure that's the
case here
if it's 10 bucks i mean you get access
to a gym that's a pretty good deal
so you just come out with a rule that
nobody knows about
everybody that comes here knows about
that rule do they
i've been here what is the rule what's
the goddamn rule
it says denies enter over water bottle
because his water bottle would not fit
in their cup holder
wait is she called the cops i'm in here
i planted fitness
with this bottle and mrs ashley cheers
she does not want to allow me
to work out because she says my bottle
will not fit into her cup hutter
which i go to multiple disgusting planet
fitnesses how could you ever have an
issue
and she could not provide me with any
written documentation
showing me that
nor is it posted anywhere in the gym
yeah right but she says everyone knows
about it how will they know about
it if it's not written down in a policy
i mean if this happened to me i'd be
like all right can i just leave it here
then
and i'll pick it up on my way out like
i'm gonna make a big fuss out of it but
still it's not shown posted
in your facility so how would everyone
know yeah
section 40. are you going to be working
out it's section 4d
[ __ ] no big drinks you're a
lugger
no one needs to drink this much water no
one
but you're not showing me anywhere in
your policy where it states that
she is she please tell me she's calling
the cops
the inside of all your cup holders i
asked you could you
provide me with written documentation
but you could not i mean to be fair you
won't have to have
a written documentation about the rules
right or do you i don't [ __ ] know
but i also it's such a dumb [ __ ] rule
description of writing this said that
you can change any rule
all i ask you to do is show me in this
gym where the sign is posted or show me
in your documentation
that says all water bottles must be fit
into a cup holder
yes she's actually doing it it's a
simple yes or no
call the cops i mean i'll leave if you
ask me to leave there's no need
i guess you're gonna you're gonna call
the cops i guess no that's fine sir cop
there's a man with a man with an
unreasonably
sized water bottle we need to stop him
see what you're doing you want to call
the police like i'm making a big problem
for you
i'll go ahead and leave if you have been
deleted but this video will be out and
you and they'll be showing you in your
face thank you
there's a man with a water bottle asking
for policies bring back up
back up now don't drop a pen at planet
fitness
don't ever that's how ridiculous this is
that can't be real that can't be real
they were [ __ ] ready with that luck
alarm right they're judging from men
free zone
what were they thinking what were they
thinking i don't
[Applause]
this woman attacks physically attacks a
man
and says i'mma kill you no one calls the
cops
but a man has a water jug that's too
large
oh what the [ __ ] called the cop straight
away
this is too much i can't [ __ ] poor
guy that works there dude
[ __ ] there's a lot of weirdos that goes
to the gym man
jesus christ i mean fair enough
is it fair enough i don't know
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] eating between each push
hell yeah oh yeah you know some people
go to the gym so they can eat more but
why waste time in between right
oh wow
how this is possible what makes people
so
confident to just go to a machine and
just say
you know what i'm not gonna read what it
says it does
i'm just gonna come up with my own idea
this is how it's meant to be
okay that just blows my mind like
there's one thing to just
not understand and if you're new fine
but this is just so confusing to me ah
they're trying to find the sweet spot
where they're strongest nope stronger
over there
[Laughter]
got it over there there's better chakra
energy at this spot
i can't i can't i can't dog on old
people
more anti-gravity machine
they can love this machine don't they
[Music]
you gotta respect the sunglasses at the
gym ain't nothing like it
it looks like footage from one of those
old-timey insane solid that's exactly it
beautiful god bless you planet fitness
god bless you jim fails i love it
it's amazing thanks for watching guys
subscribe for more content
and have a great day yeah bro fizz
check out my other gym fail video and
that's it bye bye